well if you've watched this show over
the last year you've seen us celebrate
Chris Cuomo the poet laureate of the
cable news network what began as gentle
mocking quickly became admiration and
then something like love as we watch
Chris emit a jasmine-scented cloud of
profound and haunting insights into the
human condition yes we initially wrote
him off as a semi illiterate buffoon
we'll admit that but then we came to see
the deeper truth Chris Cuomo is an
artist a seer a soul Sherpa leading his
people from the screeching chaos of this
world into the blissful clarity of the
next he is a shaman
we're his acolytes or at least we
thought we were now comes the disturbing
news that Chris Cuomo is claiming to be
something else entirely in a recent
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
Cuomo described himself not as the
Eastern mystic we imagine we want to
warn you this may come as a shock but
merely a journalist that's right a fact
man a shoe leather reporter someone who
doesn't let his own opinions get in the
way of the news that's why I came to CNN
Chris explained we'll imagine our horror
our sadness our bewilderment just a
journalist we knew him as so much more
could this be true or is it merely a
veil meant to confuse unbelievers one of
the thousand names of Vishnu here's the
Chris Cuomo we know so why am I going
that's the job there's a sense of duty
thing think back with your head not just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the hashtag stand firm please use it
just a journalist indeed you're so much
more than that Chris with abs like that
don't sell yourself short